la surprise de ce mondial aura été sans
conteste l'engouement des femmes
françaises on les disait anti foot et
pourtant elles se sont convertis au
point de devenir de véritables
supporteurs à l'image de ces femmes
d'amérique du sud ou du nord de l'europe
christelle bertrand dominique merlet en
france les femmes et il football n'ont
jamais fait bon ménage
le mondial a donné un bon coup de balai
aux idées reçues trois mois avant le
premier match
70 % n'en avait rien à faire mais la
france gagne alors un gradin comme un
ministre ça peut être aussi fini est
indifférente en fait aux sports en tant
que tel mais finalement elle n'était pas
indifférente à l'événement mondial
spectaculaire l intensité émotionnelle
et dramatique qui est en train de se
jouer comme en train de vivre la coupe
du monde c'est la grande saga de l'été
le casting le scénario tout est là pour
faire un succès les rebondissements des
épisodes français ont été suivis à 50%
par des femmes même si on va voir ça les
viseurs j'ai vibré quand même si ce
dernier moment le pouvoir et espéré
s'est croisé loin de croire au premier
rang
l'athénée a été installé et à force de
se faire mousser le football est le
sujet de prédilection dans le dernier
salon où l'on cause
au départ on s'est dit bon on espère que
les gens on n'aura pas beaucoup d'hommes
durant le match plus de femmes et est en
fait les femmes un succès pour regarder
max et le grand bleu a déteint sur un
public inattendu
le mondial c'est la dernière coupe à la
mode les françaises se sont piqués au
jeu et aux joueurs laurent blanc thuram
alors attention si on gagne ça va friser
l'hystérie